it's just been announced that the Prime
Minister Boris Johnson and his partner
Kerry Simmons have announced the birth
of a healthy baby boy at the London
hospital earlier this morning mother and
baby are doing very well so Prime
Minister Boris Johnson has another child
and that means or may explain why he
will not be attending Prime Minister's
Questions today his place is going to be
taken by the first minister and foreign
secretary
Dominic Raab that news also confirmed in
the past hour while joining me now from
Westminster is Sky's political
correspondent Kate McCann so Boris
Johnson and Kerry Simmons have a baby
morning Adam well we knew that the baby
was due in early summer and as you say
we were talking before about how strange
it was that number 10 wouldn't confirm
that Boris Johnson would be taking Prime
Minister's Questions this morning and
now we know why there's been a healthy
baby boy delivered as you say at a
London hospital earlier today and so the
Prime Minister now will face a difficult
time ahead he's just recovered from
coronavirus of course he's been away
from work for the last couple of weeks
the country is in crisis there are many
many decisions that the Prime Minister
needs to make going forward and of
course he's just welcomed a new baby boy
so difficult personal time ahead for him
he had said originally that he would be
taking some time off of course as most
new fathers do to help out bringing the
baby home and of course doing all the
tasks that go along with that but it
will be difficult for him because as I
say he's been away for a couple of weeks
we know from aides close to him that he
was very keen indeed to get back on top
of the agenda when he got back into
Downing Street on Monday particularly on
issues like personal protective
equipment for NHS and care staff he'd
made that one of his first priorities
and we do know from his speech on Monday
and Downing Street that he intends to
start thinking about how the UK could
move forward maybe not come out of
lockdown just yet but certainly change
some of those measures over the course
of the next couple of days so it's a
pretty difficult week some lovely news
of course a new baby is always welcomed
news and it's great to hear
that mother and baby are doing well but
it's such a difficult time for the prime
minister and for the country it does
present a challenge now for Boris
Johnson